you know you just mention optimizing
your performance well if you want
supplements nutrition fitness apparel
all kinds of stuff if you want to
workout online which is what everybody
do it for me run it has got you they got
Onix six barbell you can work out with
your barbell on at six body weight on a
six kettlebells on at six steel mace on
six durable row dreaming fitness battle
ropes they got all kinds of stuff you
can do whatever you want coffee - black
rifle on a cloud with [ __ ] yeah coffee
they got it all they got protein that's
a mile out dude MCT oil join it they got
health bars warrior bars everybody
basically on it is up on the latest sign
one-stop-shop he'll make the perfect
boat they were one of the first people I
think to sweeten their protein powder
with monk fruit which it doesn't spike
your insulin Evert being like a thing
about monk food and then when I was with
Aubrey it on and in Austin I went this
tastes great doesn't taste like
artificial you say mom fruit I was like
mmm
interesting so anyway it's zero body
they're up on the mound the latest yes
that's an audit dog home slash fighter
tips off on it comp size fighter Timpson
up well Brandon you're chewing on red
vines dude my my only source of calories
today was red lines just read minds this
first thing is touch these lips huh I
mean how damn I had some egg whites
Apple oh wow and some almond butter oh
wow yeah dude I gotta be on insulin
level gonna be honest your eyes they
look good not bad they look you know bad
better a little better you can see my
ear a little bit like this these seem
eyelids
see my lids still go a little under here
other than that I'm gonna be fine you
excited about San Antonio you know I
love that hotel man yeah Hotel mo I've
never been I doubt you it has a library
where I can read I was like when the
best bars has a library always like a
gentleman yeah there's a great ambiance
on the awesome put on that robe yeah I
was wondering why some restaurants make
it and others don't
and it's all about ambiance
food too like the hang2 energy humming
clubs right like yeah they mount all the
comedy clubs in LA why is the store the
best spot because it has a great hang in
the best comics but like other places
know where to hang well the store never
was the great spot and I know but I'm
just saying like yes yeah but when you
think about like you like where they say
the worst businesses go in our
restaurants
yeah and gyms yeah what makes a gym
successful what's making is what
restaurant successful restaurant I
assume number one food don't matter how
cool look in that place if your food
tastes good no matter yes well then
again if you have a place that gets a
reputation and you have tourists through
they don't care that much
that's Gingka but the Chinese have very
interesting thing called feng shui so
that they they take flow and and the
relationship between objects and you
know all that stuff very seriously to
the point well I believe when you create
a big structure they have a feng shui
practitioner come in and make sure that
all is good your house does that
Cheesecake Factory and make sure the
fence wah is good thanks way
it's a French way of saying that's why
the [ __ ] did you see that
I dream of Jarrow I think yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah jiro Dreams of Sushi yeah yeah
dude [ __ ] that place hmm where he be
like you put in your mouth and he
watches you like you beat it no no
Schultz went there was like it sucked
what Schultz whether I was like yep he
goes I got on the list I know I was
going there and I think he was with his
boy and he's like that place sucked
really they said the food's the egg
custard everything that guy did three
months to perfect egg custard that's
very Japanese though let me do one thing
over and over again so nervous son was
like rolling rice hoping to get the
promotion
yeah take over there was a book early to
son get the promotion get anymore all
right well there you go that's going to
adjust Schultz do you remember that
documentary there was a point in that
documentary where we're hero you get
everything about him you understand his
obsession did you'd remember that the
moment he said something very moving is
it when he was looking through to does
nope he was honest he was on a train I
think and he said
something that was very very moving he
said my parents didn't care about me and
you could see in his face and he's 90
that that still broke him oh dude and so
he put all his all his love and
obsession into sushi sushi looks
phenomenal he he's a master there are
always stories about in Japan practicing
one thing until you become part of it
like there was a butcher and this guy
watched this butcher who'd been a
butcher's life and the guy watched his
butcher cut meat and it looked like his
hand was just falling through it looked
like his hand wasn't doing any effort in
his hand was going like that and it and
and the butcher over you know 30 years
of deep practice that figured out
exactly where to cut so that it took
zero effort where he knew exactly the
salt Bega I don't know that guy's crazy
he's like he's they say good magician
but owns a steak house he does this yeah
it's all he's amazing mm-hmm no
definitely not that guy let me see that
guy ah
he opened a restaurant I think it's got
salt bay in Miami yeah he's he's very
Miami he's Turkish I believe and he's
awesome his videos are actually was this
song bay as in the salt babe new
syrettes or something bay stands for
before anyone else oh I'm very unhip so
when you call your girl or boy bay
that's what it means
mmm-hmm bay he's like your legit chef
huh that's what I don't mean oh [ __ ]
he's a legit butcher butcher for sure
yeah he's a stud he owns a restaurant
man you wanna watch one of these yes of
course I want
ah that's the tail
[Music]
he's nice with it
sunglasses there's something calming
about it the other is he's cooking here
Zoey's he's got sunglasses is here so no
Liam just feathering it feather
woohoo drip is you see baby slow motion
dead serious makes a mustache work and
then the famous that's his famous salt
drop no heard them all
that's exactly how Jordan shoots Oh
final n1 n1 28.4 mil as well he should
let me get a little more this guy and
he's probably at his restaurant and he's
just this guy made a career out of
salting well yeah he did ate it he
didn't do it he couldn't be more of a
Miami cause you know like a brick
[ __ ]
by the way Turks are great wrestlers
macho people apparently good butchers he
got you just got famous doing that that
meeting yeah meat and salt well he's a
butcher or slash bodybuilder Oh like
musician he's got a great sense of humor
is really what he's about
look at his hand yes all that [ __ ] up
now what
[Music]
Oh what the [ __ ] is this nothing easy
easy
ah it's a tiny hole isn't slicing your
chef you're saying he's a magician he's
a god no oh dude oh he's making it he
dead sir there's something relaxing
about this well it's because he's doing
nothing else than LeBron that's a little
bug because there's nothing there's a
lot of effort that goes yeah and he's
doing easy just totally focused
there's pictures of Connor at his
restaurant I love all the celebs yeah oh
yeah yeah and he has like really really
hot chicks that he lets feed oh they let
him feed him
yes he's he fancies himself a king
I wonder how tall he is my feeling is
low man this moment five-state yeah my
feeling is he's when you're six - you
don't need to do this is this
chicken-fried steak
it looks like you're right is this
schnitzel I never under had a shoe so go
ahead and say he's very short but who
cares chin see if he's close to any
celebrities it's a picture so I can
either who I bet that [ __ ] is fire
veno vegans please here we go
well here's a salt bay Oh make it rain
to make it ready it's snowing it's
wintertime
let's go well I don't realize that's
very good cookie she's got a whole lot
salty yeah
sodium anybody what we asking Ron see
how jolly azides want to try to find
with others will go to celebrity haunts
go down chin go to Reyes pictures in
celebrities you'll be able if we can
find him he post with him all the time
yeah I see him online all the time
you fall on chin no but he always pops
up in my explorer there's probably
Prince 263 ok well that guys wearing
lifts dr. oz dr. oz yeah I'm telling
this guy's really yeah yeah there's dj
khaled I don't know what that is oh
these which one far left
yeah yeah he's not at all Champions
League when we just go to height you
think your thawne there i just google it
he's not famous
he's the Instagram famous different
animal you know mm-hmm too salty
high five points long mr. five five yeah
and that son here's his prey fight three
he's not a target no part of what drives
him P Diddy
where's him is out the pone though yeah
I don't know that is he looks like
Armand de santé they just try you know
just doing the damn thing Halloween I
make sense oh I would like to try his
food oh here would be fun what's it
called
is it salt days
they restaurant I don't think so he has
a couple of restaurants I know yes well
the one in Miami's the main where all
the celebrity know steak houses so I'll
play this a la there's a noir set it's
called the salt bay restaurant
interesting job in New York - mm-hmm and
it's a five-star diamond award
restaurant Wow it's fantastic yeah I
love America will you come in with an
idea on Instagram and you end up
building a whole thing yeah it looks
nice yeah it does
now else we do know a steakhouse it's
good mystique a sweet Houston was it
being be butchers yeah that's their
outstanding amazing project I don't know
of any good rep people send us good
steak house in San Antonio I don't know
any I just kind of stay on campus there
at Mia would be nice to go to steak
house maybe I might be all you need
let's take off campus yeah sure
what's a will see we will see um all
right good stuff Thank You Sophie thank
you so pay the salty Bay the salty back
will stop you by you dude I'm wearing my
baseball jersey because I think it
sounds like they're gonna have a season
dude 60 game Cleveland Indians yeah I
got this when I was performing
hilarities in Cleveland but uh the salty
Bay July 23rd and 24th there's one they
expect to open it so but usually you
know they play 182 games yeah now you're
in a sixty game season I think soon
bring baseball bat really cuz it's
shorter shorter yeah every game matters
more about our people that's true and
I'll be in the stands no no people are
fresh but still I think people are gonna
kill care more then also because sixty
game seasons not so long you have the
ACE players the pitchers they're gonna
be able to pitch more so we can see more
of your best favorite players more you
know so we have now 60 games we have but
sports are going to come back yeah this
is what's guaranteed so far you have
bass welcome back 60 games
and of July you have NBA playoffs end of
July you have NFL popping up in
September all none of them are planned
with a crowd yet you have NASCAR come
back 30,000 people crowd you have golf
back UFC has been back
NASCAR's the only one with the fan base
though right now right laughs but the
the I feel like the corona virus is
spiking in a lot of states we're testing
more and now the the medium the median
age used to be like you know seven high
70s of people that have it now it's down
like 37 yeah well do these asymptomatic
yeah but which is a good thing like the
more people have it the better yeah yes
yes don't hang out the grandparents
though you see what happened with a
Bubba Bubba Wallace yes and did you see
the FBI dia report yes and that news has
been there for like a long time yeah did
he not know that did he not say that
right away what happened
no he's now he's saying that yeah it
could have been there before but he
there he saying that it's an actual
noose and they're saying it was just a
garage pole so he's and he's saying he
grew up racing I know what a [ __ ]
garage pole is compared to news this is
the news system as a news
FBI described as a news I think the
image that I have and I have seen of
what is hanging my grudge is not a
garage been racing all my life we've
raced out of a hundreds of garage that
never had garage pulls like that it was
a noose whether tied into a 19 or
whatever it was a new so it wasn't
direct at me but somebody tied a noose
that's all that's what I'm saying Jesus
we are getting pretty damn sensitive
here aren't we you're the guy who tides
right oh there it is that they're mean
come on from 2019 or the guy is just
trying to tie a good knot for the garage
great what that's a [ __ ] didn't mean to
do that you know yeah okay and you gotta
assume the guy time that I guess if he
was trying to insult Bubba Wallace it
was like hopefully picks this garage
like I don't think he was working that
garage when you tied that net not well
if you had a knowledge that you what
else would you do with that if you
needed a handle to pull it down it's
easier right yeah I don't know man but I
think now he's max people are like
you know yeah he's like [ __ ] is that so
he and he didn't see it of guy on his
team was like hey I had something to
tell you and cuz he hasn't been there as
a cemetery someone put a noose in it so
for NASCAR who makes a big deal about
the yeah I did a thing for NASCAR I
never got paid for uh I think was for a
discovery or was like a pilot for
discovery that this production company
was doing and I went to NASCAR and I saw
a guy with his trailer and he had you
know is you pull the shade out you have
your tarmac and you you know setting up
shop you sit down tailgating but this is
tailgating this was not you know yeah
and it said no Jews blacks or gays
allowed and this was in this was 1999
and I just went I looked over I went
what the [ __ ] and nobody was saying
anything so and we were that where was
that at in the South that was in
California that was actually here in
this in this state of ours I believe and
I think I can't member I think I drove
there I think it was California I can't
remember but it was not in near la
looked insane was it I can't I'm not big
tailgating guy you never had done it did
it once where they were trying to fry an
entire turkey in a in a goddamn yes in a
deep fryer dangerous by the way I would
imagine it would be dangerous you know
why because if the turkey is like fault
solid and you drop it in it was great a
lot of [ __ ] meat rocket and it you
know it kills people really oh yeah
every single year people die but Solan
has died you might be making that up
no it's all a story I've heard people
dying from you definitely we get burned
by that a lot dude a frozen flash Turkey
yeah flying it your [ __ ] face I would
be bad that would be very bad yeah there
you go
well there you go that's what happens
but but how many people have died trying
to deep-fried Turkey well that's a deep
fryer fry them
problems man I've always been scared of
it although mighty delicious tradition
deep-fried turkey I think sin can be
risky every year deep fryer fires are
responsible for 5 deaths Wow 60 injuries
destruction of 900 homes more than 15
million property damage well be careful
of frozen turkeys ok problem it's very
hot oil hey I don't like turkey in the
first place the only turkey I've ever
liked is that truth BBQ you tried it
very good
soft delicious off still turkey though
still turkey still turkey at the end
that is a turkey takes all the energy
out of my body if you get a restaurant
you're a chicken or turkey it's like why
go home all the same oh wow so when when
I want ice from a frozen turkey meets a
vat of hot oil it instantly changes to
steam and expands to 1,700 times its
original volume well that would be an
explosion
it can cause the oil to bubble over and
if an oil particle makes contact with a
flame boom you're in trouble you know I
don't like that Google goes boom you
know yeah I'm professional in our music
our language please yeah let's make you
a little more professional I want you
talking like you're my doctor Wow don't
call me bro what I say boom you're in
trouble that's so crazy yeah I've heard
those stories so I've always been super
scared of frightened turkeys I also
don't like turkey shipstation talk to me
about shipstation oh my god I want to
ship anything they want should all your
carriers if you're sending stuff you
time you at USPS FedEx UPS Amazon
whatever you're trying to get out do it
the fastest easiest most affordable way
to manage and ship your orders I'm
talking about ship station comm just a
flu flu just a few clicks Lu you'll be
managing your orders printing out labels
getting your product your happy
customers ship station makes it so dang
easy I'm more in terms of online sales
sellers and you'll ship more and less
time with the best rates available right
now fighter and kid listeners can ship
station free for 60 days when they use
all four code fighter make sure your
business is ready to meet the demands of
delivery culture get started at ship
station calm today click on the
microphone top of the homepage type in
fighter that ship station calm then
enter the code fighter ship station comm
make ship happen talk to me I'll whoop I
know you weren't
I know it's accurate we know it's got
crazy technology and thick-ass was
writing this morning and I thought about
you how far am I going cuz the app that
I'm using the app that's not before
whoop but that I was using we go oh you
burned 1,400 calories poop went yeah
cheaper nine hundred fat-ass oh well
thank you thank iPad thank you for that
cuz it tracks your strain your sleep
dude everything yeah how much sleeves
you get I think do you know I slept well
you have no idea that I don't know
you're guessing I'm take the guesswork
out start rocking whoop dude whoop goes
beyond tracking steps and focus on
something meaningful on time out strain
this is looking for how active your
heart is throughout the day calculates
that into how strenuous your day is
throughout your workouts based on your
recovery whoop provides target strain
goals which helps leads to more optimal
training if you're a part of the thick
boy by club this is key man Lube
automatically tracks work out so you can
focus just on your training whoop has a
built-in app feature that allows you to
track your strain from training in real
time you monitor your heart rate
calories burned average heart rate what
your zone heart your heart is in we're
talking about strain your workout sleep
how much sleep are you actually in
there's nothing like it may got a
five-day battery life so you can charge
it and in five days about it's
waterproof daddy it's waterproof want to
swim with low-energy
yep I don't know what that means but it
sounds awesome pretty frickin so we get
whoop can you give me some some some
money off yeah man just download the app
on your device your phone alright then
go to whoop is offering you guys 50% off
with the code fighter at checkout go to
whoop that's wh ooo P calm into the code
fighter at checkout you save 15% off
sleep better recover faster train
smarter optimize your performance with
whoop hit it fake boys when I was
playing I was doing a tailgate party I
think it was at the Giants game of the
chess game and Jimmy birth took it upon
himself to take all his clothes off and
yank his underwear into the crack of his
butt and go out for passes and he was
running out with sneakers and that
little legend yep and and he was running
imagine paddling it wasn't so cold okay
but he was catching passes and I
remember a guy came running up to him as
fast as he could and stopped and goes
whoo
Oh what are you doing like that's all I
could say well you just didn't know how
to make sense of it and Jimmy goes
playing cash and the guy goes that's
[ __ ] up
Brennan ran away so they who there's
remember the Jimmy Burton
yeah not the jury Burke from the from
Goodfellas there's a straight-up killer
he was well Jim Burke from Goodfellas
was the character that Jimmy the gent
burke was the guy that Robert De Niro
played do you know what oh yeah yeah
yeah you talked about in the he doesn't
know Irish man yeah no not knowing no
good oh but you don't dinero's guest
roles you oh my god can i watch casino
the other day oh my god Sharon Stone in
that she's [ __ ] kidding me Joe Pesci
in that phenomena come on bro
all phenom do you know I you need to
check out Netflix it came out two years
ago but just now for whatever reason but
Waco I'm seeing it dude really it's so
well done it's based off a book that is
it's a book based on I survived Waco and
I saw people who were followers of David
Koresh yeah
so it's false you were inside the house
when the FBI and the ATF agents it's so
[ __ ] up what we did to them
I know by we I mean the American
government not me but I saw a
documentary yeah crazy because what was
it because they had one that he's
amazing actor Taylor Kitsch Wow God he's
good but you know because they had the
FBI and the ATF had a blunder earlier
where they accidentally there was a guy
there's some issues some they end up
shooting the wife who was innocent yeah
but they thought for so they're like we
need something to cover this you know
well I think that was Randy Weaver on
Ruby Ridge yes
really rich so for they went white was
that the [ __ ] Jeff baby and I had yep
she was that shot to do dishes a shot
[ __ ] a shot killed her so you know so
the FBI and ATF is like well we gotta
figure out some get some good in the
girl well we know there's this call and
we've heard this child abuse and what's
interesting is this from the survivors
may look more into it there
no child abuse these kids were treated
great you had a lot of underage gals I
think he had a fourteen-year-old which
all right which at the time in Texas it
was legal if under his consent no 14 at
the time under parent parental consent
in a 14 oh really
yep Jesus Christ um oh I love that actor
Michael Shannon oh he's the negotiator
in this he's so good and then a little
little girl from Mozart excellent she's
in it do and then Macaulay Culkin's
Brothers in it but I've known the Waco
story for a while I read a book on it
but it's this from this point of view
like I want to read this book now it's
just so [ __ ] up dude it's like you see
what they did I mean it's crazy
oh it's horrible it it on fire it's
burned everybody it's it's just terrible
[ __ ] a it's like how can you do this
to people I just don't understand and
then when they're opening firing and
they're you know he's like dude there's
women and kids in here what do you and
he go stop stop stop there's women and
kids and they just start open firing and
he's like well because well I think what
happened was initially they were trying
to break any because I have a right to
defend myself I have a right to that is
not any shot and big big big I think
they shot a marshal US Marshal or
something and then they were all no I've
known so they also were so they they
came to the door and and he came out
like this and he's like we have women
children do not fire and then the one of
the dogs they had dogs on property
started going crazy and tried biting one
of the agents and he shot them so then
everyone oh [ __ ] they're shooting and
started shooting Jesus Jesus
it's dude it's when you watch it so
heartbreaking
yeah because there's kids man horrible
and then his and I was playing music
that the feds were playing really loud
music to try the basic yet remind
[ __ ] so the kids were like you know
freaking out it's just so heartbreaking
like how how do how do grown-ups people
who are in you know high powerful
positions like FBI instead like how does
anybody not guys when the [ __ ] are we
doing I think what happens is those guys
get cured up he goes yeah they get
geared up they go thank God they took
one of ours or two of ours
we gotta we gotta settle scores and
that's what happened you get a lot of
macho guys and you're not letting them
in okay we got the weaponry and that's
where it gets awkward so it's a complete
failure of leadership and leadership you
got to know that those guys the younger
the the choppers oh the soldiers one
yeah yeah it's exactly like with with
Afghan someone when we realized alqaeda
was gone we had the Taliban you had all
these you know geared up badasses just
chomping at the bit we're here so the
Taliban sort of became the target even
though they hadn't killed him the
Americans yeah and that spiraled into
this whole thing as opposed to saying
there might be a way for you guys to
share in the new government mullah omar
apparently reached out to the US
government and and when they realized
that they had no choice that they were
gonna be left out which and Afghanistan
means you're gonna get killed
yeah dad to fight so it was a lot of
that schism is handled anytime you read
a book on a war on a situation like that
there's always there's always a there's
always a decision that could be made
could've been made that would have
changed that was in the heartbreaking
yes with with Iraq the biggest decision
they made a mistake think anybody was a
bath astute and is fired guess what the
problem with that was you couldn't be
you couldn't work in government in the
military in anything unless you said I'm
a Bathurst and a bath this meant it was
you had to be part of the Saddam Hussein
party essentially and and so the
military goes were all Balthus so we had
to you can't say that you know sorry I
can't talk to you you know what I was
for the reason what then this weird
rabbit hole can't sleep the other night
you know what the oldest religion in the
world is hold on the oldest religion in
the world may very well be Hinduism yeah
I knew you in do ISM the oldest you
punish ties oldest also has the house
yeah sometimes I figure it'd be and I
didn't in I you know welcome to religion
I'm a [ __ ] but Islamics the newest yes
I thought his Lomb
is Islam because I thought Islam would
be the oldest because of the Middle East
and like Islam is Islam came after there
was Judaism then there was the New
Testament and then
Islam came so Islam actually looks at
the Old Testament which is fascinating
so having Muslims and the Jews have
probably trouble yes his LOM believes
that the Old Testament is all true yes
it doesn't say that the Old Testament
the Old Testament is the truth
and then the Islam's kind of a rebuttal
to the New Testament because Jesus said
he was God and that they believed Jesus
was a prophet but when you say Jesus is
God it's considered heretical it's
considered against God and then I
started liking the Hinduism because the
oldest religion and when you look at it
like that makes sense like you really
like they believe in you know like it's
just when you read about Hinduism like I
can definitely see reincarnation and
stuff like you know there's more than
one god and there's this for this reason
and you being a good person problem with
having a polytheistic religion like that
we have a lot more gods yeah and the
difference between that and say having a
mano like christianism is so one God so
when you have one God everybody's
brothers and sisters
everybody's equal because we're all in
the same streams right if you have a lot
of gods what happens in Hinduism is you
get a caste system but because people
that are close to the Brahmins correct
you know but then then that's where
Buddhism comes from right because they
don't have a caste system Buddhism does
not have a caste system but Buddhism
does have the idea that you have and you
have rebirths yes nice your Roberta
you're reborn into a lucky body yes a
higher birth and Ellora so so that
that's what they'll tell you those and
the same thing in in in Moroso so the
boot so the buddha was initially
essentially you could probably say a
hindu he was indian he was an indian
pretty who'd have to be right yeah he's
an Indian pretty so he then went on to
kind of create his own idea being one
with God when you're when you meditate
to his that you reach enlightenment
which means you're one with God to say
that you're one with God as a Christian
is heretical you know the biggest
religion on the planet yours the most
followers it might be Islam but but it
might be I thought it was Islam - it
might be Christianity Christian
understand mean two hundred fifty you
know who's gonna be by far the biggest
Oh Christianity but did you know that
amongst males I think it's I think it's
30 and under overfit
% don't believe in I got atheist I have
more in that poll I think the more with
like online and people having data and
you know impeding a lot of you know I
didn't grow up that religious so I'm not
that religious and that my kids not
praying that you grew up or so the more
we get away from the old days of going
to church every Sunday I think you get
more of that
yeah well the the I'm not say it's the
right thing I'm just saying they say the
more educated you are the less religious
you become but I don't think that the
two are diametrically opposed I think
you can be very religious and you can
also be very educated Isaac Newton the
father of physics knew more about
science than anybody and math and was a
genius he was very religious so yeah I
guess if you're that smart and you
believe inside there's room for science
hard to believe in well there's room for
science and myth and the power of myth
the truth of myth the idea that doing
the right thing is better than doing the
wrong thing and and that that that the
path to least resistance is walking a
righteous path it writes it but that
would be the idea if you believe in like
neurons and the stuff created started
there then I go well who created the
neurons I think well that's interesting
and when I was looking at religion I
thought I thought Islam would be by far
the biggest because so many Muslims you
know in the Middle East and China and
India all this you know I figure all of
15 so boom all South American Christian
most of the United States question is so
big Europe is a Christian nation I'm
Christian continent pretty much yeah all
of all of Russia and huge Christian
populations in like Korea and probably
even China did you guys grow up going to
church cat no I always raise Buddhists
that's me
are you still Buddhist yeah but I'm not
very religious I'll go to the temple
once in a while when I read up on
Buddhist swishy as I'm old I'm like
alright that makes more sense to me than
any of these other religions it's just
for me I just makes more sense to me
yeah yeah yeah you grew up doing Church
I think for a little while Christian too
but I don't really practice you know
yeah but yeah for a little while but
then we've stopped
about us I mean I've been to church once
twice mmm uh well my parents just didn't
my grandparents kind of rely on yeah I
wanted a bunch times I was younger then
me and my brother got old enough Frank
did what do we hate this yeah we threw
the biggest fits my dad's okay let's
stop going and then you know I would go
to a Bible study when I first moved to
LA twice a week for like a year yeah
happy about you you know there is a lot
of value i people think there's no value
no I know there's there's a no religion
whatever here there's good value and
there's good lessons there's good
takeaways if you take it you know word
for word you and I think you'd be over
analysed you're like what are you
talking about man but the overall
messages and into anything you believe
are good you take good from it I learn
stuff from it I don't believe in it but
I there's good messages and you know it
makes you and well there's a dent in
taking it literally and taking it
symbolic yeah yeah so there we have it
yeah I stopped going when I was talking
to someone part who's part of the group
and like you know it's important that
you convert and accept Jesus in your
life and like yeah I hear you man you
know and they go because you know if you
don't hey what do you mean I go well my
dad my brother their you know their
atheist they don't believe in they go
then they're going to hell yeah I went
oh I'm not coming back you're using fear
yeah well I'm not coming back that's not
true yeah the nice true Jordan Peterson
does a very good job of creating space
for both religion and science and
meshing the two that's what his
contribution has been he's amazing I
mean he just makes he's very religious
but also very scientific interest and he
makes a [ __ ] great art elitism or to
him and and you Val Harare in his book
sapiens does the same thing a half step
in yes the power the power of story and
how that can make a huge difference yeah
so there we have it ladies gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen get some current
events Jen sure here we go okay so a
older woman in a San Jose Yogurtland is
currently being sought after by San Jose
Police Department because she
purposefully went up to a woman who had
her child in a stroller
and she coughed on the child multiple
times why they're saying that they think
it's because she was upset with the
mother for not being socially distant
enough but the mother personally thinks
that it might be various related cuz it
happened after she started speaking
Spanish to her mother I'm not sure is
there any possibility that you haven't
said that's such a cute baby and she has
introducing kind of frozen treat bars
you be like you'll be like whoa frozen
treat bars you be like whoa we have a
new be like used of intentionally
coughing on a one-year-old boy at a
yogurt land in San Jose this is new
video of the incident just released by
the San Jose Police Department so look
at the right side of your screen the
woman seems to point to the ground then
approaches a mom standing with her son
in a stroller nearby watch as the one
woman just pulls down her mask and then
she coughs two to three times in the
baby's direction police say the woman
was upset believing the mom wasn't
maintaining proper social distancing
yeah I mean III people sucked it yeah
just people also like alright this is
more like at the baby and kind of get
away she's an older woman who was
probably afraid of Corona cuz if she
gets it she could die
I could also don't do that to be mad
enough yeah why'd you do that to the
wrong persons baby there's me Reba cos
gonna be repercussions me recovery
concussions people get a little crazy
when you mess with their babies so this
woman was out and she was working for
Amazon at the time she delivers packages
she read the special instructions and
saw that somebody put to knock the door
three times scream abracadabra as loud
as you can and run away super fast and
it turns out that the woman who ordered
the package her son went in a teenage
boy and
he typed this in to see if she would do
it and the mom forgot about the package
altogether
one day she checked her ring footage and
saw that this woman did this asked her
son about it and her son's like oh I
didn't know she would actually do this
but they ended up giving her a really
good review on him I wonder if that's
because she thought that's that's the
signal like you know like I don't know
let me see it surprise had fun with it
yeah this is Ray well that poor job can
get kind of boring so why not do
something fun it's also fun yeah take
off I love oh she took the Huff though
dude it's a to run away yes run away as
fast as you can it's pretty good
let's you jump the whole staircase funny
very impressive and this is just a
really quick one um there is a 73 year
old bodybuilder that went on to
America's Got Talent and I just wanted
to show this to Ryan I'm talking about
here is my here is my inspiration my
name is Terry Crews took his shirt off
yes jack he's jacked she's 73 years old
that's crazy
no not I'm not trying to win up this
lady she's that know worked on our face
that's cool here's the other thing
my uncle pax was 71 we won mr. universe
Jack to the guild really I've been back
spiel ba that's impressive though no
that's that's cool well it's what's
impressive visitor her skin so tight
like her stomach there's no there's no
and this is she definitely it's done I
didn't
b.o.b ei le mr. universe if you go to
him what he was seen there on his back
he was senior many one their senior mr.
universe right there yep Wow
Jesus whoa Wow I'm sorry body bill until
he was frickin
I mean 50 he was a boxer right Olympic
boxer son he's jacked you up yeah he was
your favorite huh
my favorite yep never touched this deer
right yeah so I joke I know it's gonna
say this yeah probably not true
nope not true it all works for him and
that's after he had bypass heart surgery
oh my god you just said start doing
bodybuilding good god is that him no if
you go up to it where he's flexing he's
on stage there chin you see him yeah
there he is he's 60 something there dude
that's [ __ ] crazy nuts you know what
you're gonna be doing in your future
buddy yeah you're both in shape that
outfit is one of the greatest things
I've ever seen
well he would wear that when we go to
dinners no he wouldn't dude she would
huge wear body burn clothes that
everywhere we went
dude five-star restaurants were in San
Francisco give this old royal
rolls-royce you just hit cars in like
Park and get out and like you're in
spandex packs you'd go that's top steak
houses but everyone knew mr. Venice and
he'd be walking like that [ __ ] Wow
always in something that was very
form-fitting that's addressed every time
that is a colorful man oh dude he's a
legend Jesus good for him good for him
is right strong guy that's big weights
yeah played football yeah yeah man oh
man whoa well she's no joke either he
has to be 80 something there Jose yeah
he had the best stories man he's time
out when you know he's a young man and
he was you know doing his thing and he
was in this long-distance relationship
because he grew up in Oakland and his
arch nemesis was Clint Eastwood and he
said this is how they became
arch-nemesis cuz clean Clint Eastwood I
guess was a good football player in high
school and he played for the rival high
school and then he was dating this girl
in LA and they
they he would fly back and forth and do
the stuff and he was like you know I
figured we were do dating you know I'd
see her multiple times a month and four
months and stuff like that he goes and
then I'm over a house you know we just
got done doing the I think said the
shebang I'm like okay and he goes and
she's in the shower on the phone ringing
and he was the phone rings back then a
full ring he's important it was answer
phone and it was a guy and he goes
answer fire hello and he the guy say he
goes well who's this is this pact spheal
it's who's this it was this Clint
Eastwood because that's how I found out
she was cheating um no Sean yeah son of
a [ __ ] so buddy that's tough that's
nice you got to be like you win all
right thank you thank you yeah finito me
Jesus
yeah packed up the best stories man the
last stories Clint Eastwood back in the
day was such a baby was I so is Paxton
what does this girl look like that's
what I want to add to it I want to know
oh dude look that second picture Inchon
come on do have me how can I be nice
compete what can they do yeah dime pee
dude well straight up movie star his son
looks just like I'm right
yes god that's good yeah yeah yeah oh
wow he's not Scott's not his big toe
nice tall yeah like Clint like tall like
dude they look well clinched all and
Clint's also a musician and a director
and he does it all and the Clint would
score his own mutant movies what yeah
definitely not anymore do they
nobody no they don't Clint Jesus Christ
you know they the piano oh yeah really
well play piano and actually compose I
mean did the scores for his movies
there's some guys that you see like this
just like what a [ __ ] town I know
it's just like it's unbelievable yeah
you got like Paul Newman him you know
you character just like the jack of all
trade just a guy's guy yeah just
everything they did they don't miss now
good-looking take care themselves the
answer and six three yeah
yeah there's no more like real Hollywood
slab like that now no now he was just a
massive movie star we're talking I think
that's aa great Charles right yep
Wow yeah I think that Clint Eastwood
wrote directed and starred in his own
movie the lot of his of you'll well he
also did like last year dude he's 91
High Plains Drifter the I mean what is
it called for Unforgiven I mean he's got
it goes on not as the good the bad and
the ugly this is my generation and even
before yeah no joke what a like I gotta
pee what a life that guy said I got seen
big I got a question for him um it's a
little off the subject
I feel like Gustafson and heavyweight
and heavyweight would be a nightmare for
all of them okay hopefully you know with
dust furnace just how bad he wants it
you know here's all the town in the
world he'd be the best fighter pound for
pound of all time if DC and John Jones
were born I don't know yeah I know it's
just that before yeah you know so um
because it's heavyweight boy he's just
on so you just gotta hope that the speed
translates oh yeah huh you know you know
how would like Luke Rockhold went up to
205 yeah he looked so slow
yeah I got you gotta hope that yeah the
speed comes with him but you know but
that do his natural weight would I think
lend itself to being in shape I don't
know I mean I my lies naturally with
Lennon he's one of my favorite people in
UFC I hope it happens but yeah that
fights this weekend right chin is he's
he's on the hooker uh Dustin Poirier
card I'm not sure let me check I'm
almost positive he's fighting this
weekend this is parade number two four
four four two three or four
well he hasn't fought since could be
maybe three
hmm is he not oh is he on the July 11th
car guys part on the later one that card
this Saturday's fun though we'll watch
in San Antonio I want to I would assume
Gus Finn's uh let's go to your favorite
yeah you see five five five five weeks
like they're just slinging them out
slaying them out Guzman burns what
you're calling that freshmen
really yeah it's not popping up huh no
it's just covered it might've July 25th
oh so we had some time what a great
fight though oh yes gusting beats for
Doom I mean he's there
crazy yeah he's so talented man one of
my favorite people really okay
oh great great great guys so talented
such a beast a Viking superstar a Viking
wipers on sweetie I'm sure boards
everywhere oh yeah
forget it one of the most talented guys
I've ever seen man you Tony
Oh tell me he was just I know just an
him get ready for the Mitrione fight cuz
we're fighting the same card he's
fighting john jones i was fighting man
and think carts we decide to train
together and I drove down to San Diego
Lex was with me Tony Jeffries came with
me and all these plans I go on their
first round he [ __ ] starches I mean
just a right hand from Sweden straight
to my face
oh then went three rounds after that
even though it's concussed and then
turned just like I think we need to call
it that day see you man see your honor
Thanks although I was like you know I'll
just I'll just wrestling no see you know
how's he go he hit me right here I'm
just get a restless cake well no he's
really good at that
yeah I said now you're not gonna taking
what I tell why I said this when he
fought John my prediction was he's gonna
take John down sure enough he did I
didn't know he's that good of a wrestler
I did not know he was a monster a
monster oh dude
his job so Joseph in spite of all time
he's also he's huge he's huge
John's toughest fight of all time yes a
lot of people think each on that day yep
first fight second fight John Joe got
knocked down the second but he killed
yeah that's how good John is by the way
correct yeah they still don't know
what's going on with him got two
heavyweight
well they got whether he wants do they
just wants the money they're not paying
no don't blame him
you have any more current events that's
it we got a few
oh yeah morgue yeah what's up dog here's
some a violent one upon oh yeah a
shootout
well Pasadena yes and did I think this
took place in May but then this body cam
footage just came out so let me play
this good for you it's scary
tonight we're getting our first look at
dramatic police dash camera video it
shows a violent crash at the end of a
pursuit in Pasadena and that's when the
bullets start flying Pasadena Police
just releasing this video from a pursuit
on May 8 the fleeing driver hits a
police cruiser head-on checking out
driver then the drivers firing through
the windshield the bullets hitting you
just wants to die yeah suicide by cop we
go stuff and check him out he gets out
keep shooting firing at officers who
then fire back the gunman has been
identified as 47 year old Lloyd Nelson a
former passenger resident in addition of
a gun he used to fire at officers two
more weapons were found inside his car
investigators say Nelson had a military
background and was also a former police
officer he died at the scene yes in the
hail of bullets one Pasadena officer was
shot in the leg by another officer he's
expected to make a full recovery so that
is god damn that's a dangerous job
former police officer a former military
guy - what was the deal they said he was
just acting erratic when he's driving so
they try to pull him over and then he
just went crazy Jesus Christ he might
have been flashbacks or whatever the
hell expenses then wow he starts firing
through the [ __ ] glass
good God good God
all right this is a guy holding a shark
this is what this is nuts there's like I
caught a shark with his bare hands
well okay so I'll play the video first
and he's bodied up yeah he's all ripped
hmm that's a that's a large shirt no so
like if you look into the video there
was someone already fishing so they
caught that shark and he was essentially
holding it so they could take the hook
out people are saying like he's you know
being brutal or you know we call it
cruelty - yeah by the way going in there
and doing that with a shark they can
bite so hard he's a good guy yeah help
the shark Delaware did you see the
fishing pole there what a nice gotta
help the shark yeah yeah catch and
release
without that dead shark was that close
and took that bait I don't like when I'm
in the like at the beach and a guys
fishing with a giant rod that's why I
don't do it - I love surf fishing but
there's people there I'm not gonna do oh
no no hell no they do it a lot now for
the fourth will you talk about that well
I will be in Utah I believe with my
children George like chillins not
nothing George yeah so I see that'll be
fun any plant I mean are we having a
show on Friday yeah oh wait when do you
go I will leave on the 3rd so I'd be
Friday yeah
Friday day no Friday at 5:00 oh yeah I
have a party over here at my friend's
house another one has all the
firecrackers why I work so much I don't
like big crowds and I don't either
I think the fans are a hotel shooting or
some tease favorite ya know when I was a
kid 4th of July was a big deal buy
fireworks light them off yeah you can't
do [ __ ]
there are always stories about you go
down to Mexico and get dynamite ladies
done yeah I'm a teaser for us you drive
to Wyoming and buy whatever you wanted
blackcats really oh yeah Wyoming Wyoming
oh they are illegal there so will it
drive to one last frontier yeah anymore
my friend drives to Vegas just to get
those fireworks somewhere in Vegas Vegas
is still good to do it somewhere there's
a there's a place in Vegas to a dirt
road something like yeah well you get
it's not illegal you can get you know
the Big C ah they're the ones a flight
label up like Disneyland type of
fireworks not as good but now the
secret's out so when you go their secret
a long line yeah I love fireworks yeah
all right have you seen rebel Wilson
lately I've not she got down like Adele
oh not as much but I'm pretty good all
right Jess she's looking really good
yeah yeah good for her good for her post
Malone apparently shaved his head you
went bald and put uh skeleton and I
heard no well skeletons are cool oh
there you go I have cut my hair even
shorter also skeletons are cool
spread your heart as much as you can
that little love goes further than you
think stay strong keep kicking ass love
Austin all right
Bravo yeah pretty cool a lot of face
tattoos I think he's gonna end up
covering his entire face cuz it seems
like he's not stopping
that's a tough look and we talked about
some of these already oh this this kid
he played alfalfa and The Little Rascals
so remember the scene it was this scene
[Music]
so that was him and that reminded me of
when they did it with you do you
remember this bag in there yes the face
incredible yeah so now what happened you
got arrested yeah for huffing huffing
you can't huff duster cans I guess it's
illegal to do it the act of it and they
arrest you if you huff a kid
yeah but I just feel bad because all
these little child stars for the reason
begin 2001 yeah you don't want your kid
acting and dancing and [ __ ] in Hollywood
never nope dude live your life and then
go then yeah and see Craig do other
things learn how to navigate the world
would they risk for huffing though it's
like it sucks like he isn't even doing
it um this is just some the rock I saw
him in this outfit and I just thought
cam hey is interesting campaign-style
it's a little much right jack looking
good Rock anyhow he's jacked definitely
jockeys shoulders yeah he's now so Jack
city yeah now that's a lot of
weightlifting in a lot of other stuff
well steroids I'll say that yeah he
looks a little softer in the last couple
of its I did the otter show cute
yeah see like right here don't look a
lot of what you just a lot of weight
looks like Mindy's with it there's a lot
of work you know that goes even if
you're on stuff there's still a lot of
work yeah he's Jack dude use does you
look a little bit less ripped off for
some reason
well you can't keep ideal role or
something you know you can't keep that
kind of yeah you know when you're when
you're gonna go shoot a scene you we
work out and all that stuff a gamer
yeah I don't know how famous this guy's
pro not that famous but he just showed
his recovery how he looked when he was
on benzodiazepines and opiates and then
750 or seven or 45 days later that's him
afterwards
no wonder what are those drugs those
paint no painkillers no those are for
anxiety like xanax they're at a computer
all day doing your stuff you're going to
things are gonna happen then you add
drugs
well computer games to Aybar say I don't
feel well I wouldn't say
dude Enzo pain and opiates and play
video games for fifteen hours a day
you'll feel little better feelings way
better it's amazing yeah your body
literally creates new cells new sounds
yeah sorry I don't work that's my throat
yeah a lot got a little lock they got
one more um so I don't know what this is
but do you know what QA nan is do you
know this Brian okay so because it's
sort of the right wing
yeah conspiracy theory up or something
like that so this this particular cut
man you've seen him that you see many
many times huh he was wearing a patched
representing yeah he wore patched
representing that you ain't on well I
think a lot of his new world or against
a new world order against globalism
against I think I think it's sort of
like an anti-government yes so he said
he was like he liked it because of
certain messages were like it's right
there you know where we go one we go all
we're Americans country built for
everybody all that stuff but then it
also has that other conspiracy stuff
that was dangerous like pizza gate and
everything else
yeah and then the UFC has prohibited
people from wearing anything belonging
to that group yeah because the the
actual conspiracy theories or not
there's no there's no truth to and it
harms people oh yeah you have to be
careful yeah there's there's a whole
thing I don't know I don't know much
about it so don't come after me if your
quaint honor I don't know about either
but he saw he was wearing a patch that
kind of represents that yeah I think
Trump was mentioning it I think a lot of
it's against the deep state justice and
and calls into question the collusion of
the media with government I don't know I
have no it was there's so much to read
up on but yeah it's pretty much what
you're saying I do not know I don't but
it's just it was weird that he was
wearing a notch look it up let's see
what it says I mean there's a wiki right
here but it's pretty long acquaintance
is a far-right conspiracy theory
detailing supposed secret plot by
aniline deep State against us against
Donald Trump right and his supporters
etherium to 20 2017 of Anam anonymous
imageboard 4chan by someone using the
name q who is presumably an American
individual
initially but probably became later a
group of people right it's that movie V
for Vendetta you know anonymous it's
like it's a group that kind of wants to
fight the there's a worldwide cabal
satan-worshipping pedophiles who rule
the world essentially and they could
control everything they control
politicians they control the media they
control Hollywood and they cover up
their existence essentially and they
would be you know yeah yeah I mean
that's a lot of that's a lot of
organization this is the last one so
this particular scientists I wish I
remember his name what are you saying
that there she there could be up to 36
other civilizations out there that we
just can't contact right now like
actually literally proof they're doing
math on this so here we go how life
forms on earth our own solar system we
know how long it took we know what kind
of metallic see that is kind of metals
we have and if you look at those other
stars in our galaxy have those
properties you'll be able to come up
with this number 36 huh so why haven't
we heard from any other life yet that's
a decade-old question is known for
firming
very rare all right we just can't reach
them but there's there could be 36
different like civilizations like ours
existing right now in another space-time
continuum ladies and gentlemen says
we've only been emitting light for a
hundred years
why what yeah sending radio signals to
galaxies for about 100 years and 100
light years how far that could have
travel but that's not very far Wow
it's just that they're so far away
predicting it would take thousands of
years for radio missions on earth to
reach them day m and that's good vast
play it's a vast place that's it Jay
that's Israel so it's Christopher
console Asst professor of astrophysics
can't reach em okay yeah something I
have a very I'm not I don't don't read
books on astrophysics it's not one of
the things I've been I got serious out
there but we're never gonna reach it
when you contemplate how
big the universe is it is it can be
all-consuming oh my god it's like
there's gotta be so what's going on of
course there's life someday yeah follow
you're a kid I didn't believe it at all
but then now I believe it oh yeah how
could there not be yeah that vast a
universe if light travels in 186,000
miles per second 186,000 miles per
second I believe and it takes a thousand
years to get to where it's going how far
is that how far away is that I think
about that that's it well that's a
30-yard light-years away
oh okay it's kind of far hopefully they
come to us okay I'll tell you the bank
done yeah thank you Tony oh you can bank
on us be in San Antonio Thursday Friday
Saturday you're dang right you can
you're dang God darn goddamn right work
cited yes we had a show Thursday Salt
Lake City all shows are sold out but we
had a Thursday show that's the 16th of
July our first big boy bike club ride
will be on the 18th sign up at thick boy
ride at gmail.com spoken as well first
ride will be there will be August first
sign up at fake boy ride at gmail.com
for that as well tan and Irvine tickets
will be on sale also in end of August
I'm in Tampa
Austin Nashville get your ticket Stevo
calm what's up Road Dogg de said that
when you're in Salt Lake I will be in
Dallas Addison 16 17 18 it's just not up
yeah Jack got a call okay yeah I get it
going papa
yeah um anything boy merch get you some
they restocked the store so go get it
thick boy calm let it be
yes sir I did it buddy we did it buddy
I'm gonna call Jay right now this final
kid we're out